here's the big question so how does a
new filmmaker even get the first
appointment
how do you get the first time in there
here's how i think you get it in
i believe you have three movies
currently on netflix
did you pitch all of those movies
yourself to netflix
okay so the three movies so first of all
full out is the first movie it's a
gymnastics movie
the second one is called kiss and cry
it's a skating movie and the first one
the third one is called fallout 2 you
got this
which is actually starting on january
1st so it's already sold and delivered
to netflix
but they're actually starting airing it
on january 1st
it it's another gymnastics move they
were supposed to start it during the
olympics last summer but of course there
were no olympics
so they held it until january so but
they're all i i say it's on because it's
delivered
and that's when it's going to start
worldwide so did i so i pitched
luckily back then when i pitched the
first one they were open to hear pitches
from independent
producers i got lucky because the timing
they were a big company but they weren't
what they are today so they were still
taking pictures from indie producers so
i went in there and i pitched them
myself
and you know i learned a lot it's it's
it's a
whole different style they get so many
pitches i didn't know this back then
you got to keep those pitches really
short get to the point really sweet
because they get
so many of them that they get tired of
hearing them
so they just want to make a quick
decision and hear what you got to say
so i pitched it i pitched it too long i
had like a half an hour meeting and i
probably took 20 minutes to pitch that
other than you know 10 minutes of
pleasantries
today i pitch in two minutes two to
three minutes max
that's all i that's all it takes because
they they generally know
right so i pitched it and they said okay
sounds good we like it let's do it but
we don't want to take delivery from you
because you're an indie producer
we want to take delivery from a
distribution company that we're already
set up to do business with
because we don't want to set you up as a
new client in our database
it's too much work for us so i said but
i'm also a distributor
i have my own distribution company and
um
i i make delivery i'm like i make
perfect delivery
to the distributors or to i'm making
delivery to broadcasters around the
world so
delivery is not an issue and they said
yeah but we're so busy we have so much
going on
we would prefer that we put you through
a distributor and i said
i don't have a problem with that except
for they're going to charge me a full
fee for doing nothing i mean i pitched
you i did the sale
you want the movie i'm gonna have to pay
their full commission
and they said jeff you seem like a sharp
guy figure it out
go negotiate it figure it out so they
gave me a list of
like six or seven distributors that they
recommended who i could do
business with i met with two of them i
chose one of them
and i cut a good deal but not a
fantastic deal
because i had no leverage they knew that
i was sent there so
i had to deliver through another
distributor
and i was kind of a little peeved by it
but you know what it was netflix that's
what they wanted and
what am i going to argue i mean you know
so that i had i had to do that deal
and it worked out well the other people
they did the deal
then they actually happen to be a good
distributor they did some other deals
too and it worked out pretty well
so i can't complain about it so the
second time around
same thing go to netflix pitch them on
the movie
love it let's do it i said guys please
don't make me go through a distributor
they said jeff you know the rules you
got to go through a distributor
i said how many times do we have to go
down this anyways
same thing happens i go i use a
different distributor this time
because now it's different times i
actually make you know a different type
of deal and it works up
third time around
let's do it please let me just deliver
to you please let me deliver to you
if i fail i said listen if i fail don't
even pay me the licensing fee if i don't
deliver on time
per exactly per your specs which i'm
doing anyways to these other
distributors i said i'm already
they're doing nothing they're just
pushing a button to send the materials
that i've given them
i i have your delivery list and your
specs i make that i do all the delivery
items
please just give me a chance the third
time they did
so now it's direct and if there's
netflix people watching
thank you very much i really appreciate
that you let me have that chance and i
made delivery i make delivery two months
ahead of their delivery schedule
and everything's fine and they already
confirmed delivery
and it's perfect delivery and you know
their delivery schedule is five pages
long
i mean and by the way i have to deliver
those movies in 18 languages
and and six subtitles 20 there's 25
versions of them
and uh i mean delivery alone is a lot
more money than a lot of indie
filmmakers spend on making their movies
just making delivery all the soundtracks
all the m e tracks
everything i mean it's it's a very very
extensive process making delivery
but there's you know companies you use
who are certified you know
um i forget what they call them not
aggregators uh
whatever they're they deliver they
specialize in
in delivering to netflix and you hire
them and they do your your dubs and
you're this and you're that and you just
have to manage it all
and then you know some stuff you do your
own stuff your own artwork and things
like that
yeah making delivery is is a big part of
the business and you have to do it
properly
but i really appreciate that netflix
gave me the chance to do it
and i did it properly and uh and
hopefully that
you know i mean i again that's part of
distribution
how did you get the appointment to to
pitch to even know that your pitch was
too long originally
and you shortened it down because at
heart i'm a sales guy
i mean you know i remember i went from
law school into the sales department of
a distribution company
that's what you do you you get
appointments and you meet with people
and you pitch them
and you have to be super super tenacious
and and very persistent and polite
and the most important thing is you have
to
here's here's the motto i tell everybody
who works for me
you can quote me on this no means not
today
everybody starts with a no everybody
starts with a no and if you take no as
the definitive answer you cannot
survive in this business i say no means
not today it means
i'm not going to give you the
appointment today i'm not going to give
you the deal i'm not going to give you
i'm not going to even talk to you i'm
not going to return your email
i don't take that as personal rejection
that's part of the business
it's a pain in the butt but it's part of
the business and i just keep
at it over and over and over in a very
nice way
i assume that that's part of the
business and
i have 22 years of experience getting
those
there's lots and lots of no's lots of
doors shut on your face lots of
no return phone calls thousands tens of
thousands of them
but you know ultimately if you believe
in your product
and you know that you have something to
offer to them you know sooner or later
they'll
maybe you know give you a shot
i used to say you know it takes a
hundred calls to get an appointment
i don't say that anymore now i say it
takes 250 calls to get an appointment
the number's gone up so if you know that
going into it
and you know for all the people who were
have worked with me in my office
they know that that's true they might
say no jeff you're wrong it's now 300.
you know and but we you know that that's
part of the process
and you just deal with it and you'll
live with it and it's it's it's
is it a little depressing and
aggravating yeah of course it is
you know and are people totally rude and
you know not returning any emails or
calls it's
part of the process and when you went in
the third time to pitch
what are you bringing with you just a
log line synopsis
okay i'm an anomaly don't
independent producers who are watching
this do not assume this is this is this
is the blair witch project this is
this is not what normally goes on okay i
had a track record from two other films
if i didn't have that i wasn't even
gonna get every single time you do it
it's a new adventure
yeah so they know that i can make the
movie on time and on budget on a quality
movie
that helps open the door and get the
appointment to start with
all right secondly
everything got delivered on time and
thirdly they did well with the movies
had they not done well i wasn't going to
get another appointment
it's business it's all statistics they
look at their little
ipad in front of you and they say okay
your numbers are
they don't tell you the numbers because
that's you know
confidential um but if your numbers
aren't good
one you're not getting an appointment
and two you're not getting a deal
so so how do you here's the big question
so how does a new filmmaker
even get the first appointment how do
you get the first time in there
here's how i think you get it in you got
to go in with somebody else
you got to go in with an established
producer who has a track record who
you can make believe in you or who does
believe in you and can hold your hand
through the process
and give you that credibility and that
experience because
not only what the streamers want and the
broadcasters but your investors the
investors want
they want to know that you're going to
be able to deliver what you say you can
deliver
and if you haven't done it before it
doesn't mean you can't do it you
probably can do it
it just means they don't know for sure
that you're going to be
and so they want to bet on somebody
who's done it before
so for say a streamer to you know
say okay you know jeff will make sure
your product's gonna get delivered on
time and on budget equality
or an investor i guess i have a track
record
that helps it really helps to have a
track record and that's sort of what all
the agencies have and all you know
these are the people want to do business
with people that they've already done
business before because it's more
predictable
so getting in the first one or two times
is way more difficult
because you don't have a track record so
i think the best way to do that is to
hook up with somebody who does
unless you can get super lucky and you
know get your own appointment
and where would one meet a person of
this caliber yeah that's the problem
i mean generally you're going to go on
the internet and you're going to watch
all these
webcasts and interviews and all this
kind of stuff and all these people who
are claimed to be you know
teachers and master classes and this and
that and and
pros and it's tricky it's tricky i mean
but you kind of opened it up for me to
do a pitch for myself here
i mean i do consulting for those
people to find other people so i don't
necessarily do that
for people um i have done it i have done
a couple of projects where i've i've
mentored them once in a while i'll do
that but
usually what i do is as a consultant i
hire myself as a consultant
to hook those people up with other like
people
either certain genres because by the way
like when you're dealing with netflix
now
there are i don't know there's got to be
a thou
i know 500 to a thousand buyers i mean
there's so many
departments now with so many little
niches
so if you fit into this category like if
you're horror
psychological thriller blah blah blah
blah blah there's like maybe five
different categories and you need to go
into the right one so you got to be
hooked up with somebody who kind of
knows how to navigate that one
it's a little tricky these days okay
here's here's another question
so i'm at an event let's say and
it's it's maybe film oriented
and maybe it's afm whatever
how am i approaching someone i see them
from across the room i realize you know
what this person
could get me in that door yeah how am i
approaching them where i'm not
disingenuous how i'm not
this sleazy l.a sort of opportunist
or maybe all the rules go out the window
great great question and and it really
boils down to
how do you do it in a bar i mean you
know like it just depends on who you are
what mood you're in how many drinks
you've had you know it really does it's
it's a chemistry thing you know that's
sure yeah
you know it's true like sometimes you
just feel a little more
daring sure um you don't want to be that
sleazy la
type of thing nobody wants that but
you know sometimes people respect and
you know it could be like i don't know
how to do i was never great in a bar
ironically i'm pretty good in a sales
room but like i'm not that good in a bar
um i just don't feel comfortable in that
environment i hear you and it's the same
standing in the lobby at the afm and the
lowe's hotel there it's it's
tricky it's really trick and they're
usually talking to people they always
look so busy
you don't want to interrupt so
[Music]
that's got nothing to do with filmmaking
and everything to do with interpersonal
skills and and confidence and and
humility and
whatever it's it's chemistry yeah i
think that's a fair answer
you're right and and there are people
that are masters at it i see them at
starbucks
i see them wherever and they're just
they just have that it factor where they
can start conversations
yeah and it's not over the top i need
something from you right
and then there's other people and i and
i can't even say that they're trying to
be sleazy or disingenuous it's just
it's just an approach yeah and i think
some people just you're right i
don't really feel comfortable in bars
either so i get it's a it's it's a
it's a chemistry thing yes i know that's
the word i use yeah yeah that's a good
point
and i don't know if chemistry i guess
can be manipulated i don't know
yeah yeah i mean it's also you know it's
funny the all these markets ha
and festivals have these big parties
right the problem with the parties is
they're so loud you can't really talk to
anybody you can't engage but maybe
that's better
you know you can i don't know it's it's
it's a social dynamic that it's it's
tricky you know i generally approach it
as
real business like that's who i am just
a real
straight-up business guy which isn't
sometimes that doesn't work a lot of
people want it to be more social
and i you know yeah but then sometimes
the ones that are really good at that
it's
it's like a flakiness so there's a
really fine line to it
yeah i don't think and it depends on the
other person right how they receive that
some people like to be you know have
that flaky thing some people don't
but you don't know because you're
another person so you have no idea right
it's like blind dating
yeah no that's that's true good point
have you only pitched
netflix three times and you're
successful at all pitches or there were
more times there were more times
yeah i forgot to mention that oh yeah
there were many more times when they
they were not as receptive which is fair
game
right you can't like everything but it
taught you something
i know it's a cliche but you learned
shorten the pitch maybe
what they like no it's not they they
didn't like it they didn't like what i
had to offer so
far is very you know you can't expect
everybody to like everything
okay i mean you know i respectfully
disagree i think the other stuff i
pitched was
some ways even better but didn't happen
that time
but my motto is no means not today so
those are on the back burner
there will be another cycle i will pitch
them again i have to wait for new people
to come in sometimes or you know
people to change departments or whatever
and then you know you do it again
are you bringing in art like key art as
well or no
that doesn't factor in oh yeah yeah i
mean
yeah especially at a streaming company
um yeah
at a distributor you don't have to
because the distributor wants to make
the key art
so they they actually don't want you
they want to do it okay unless you've
had it done professionally really good
and you're a good artist whatever
i always bring in key art one little you
know to give it's it it gives a visual
image
and i and i bring in a trailer and key
art and
a log line that's it that's all you need
it's pretty short and sweet
and so then how does it go okay great
they tell you right there
no we can't do this they say we'll let
you know yeah
it said we'll let you know it's a it's
uh
but you can after you leave those
meetings
you analyze that we'll let you know for
a long time
was it a good we'll let you know was it
a medium one was a bad one like
you know was there an inflection it was
a reflection
what was it there's an
you drive yourself crazy sure sure and
then you just hope that on your
follow-up
you know you get a good result and then
do you do you so what's your time frame
for
following up i usually ask them when i
should follow up
you know i actually i used to ask now i
say i'll follow up with you in a week is
that okay
um so because you don't want to appear
that you're
bugging them or pestering them or
whatever and so you do
and you got to be good at follow up and
then uh you know hopefully get a
response if you don't you politely
follow up you know a couple days later
everything's got to be polite and
professional even though
they're not necessarily i'm not saying
netflix i'm netflix netflix is actually
the most professional show
i've ever done absolutely i'm not saying
that for the video it's true
yeah they their follow-up is
unbelievable they return their call
for me anyways i've been lucky that my
buyer has been super super responsive
and polite
and professional whereas some people
you'll never hear
anything from them distributors
primarily if you wonder if your email is
even working
you didn't get a bounce back but like
you often wonder
you know so you follow up politely be as
professional as possible
and you know just sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't
you